[Musik]
eine schweizer fan namens daktari mitten
in namibia kann sie keine landwirtschaft
hier ist alles irgendwie etwas anderes
der boss ist eine frau roth rügte rapid
auf daktari drogensüchtige jugendliche
aus der schweiz deutschland und
österreich
zusätzlich plant sie jetzt rinder zu
züchten
die tiere werden im moment günstig
versteigert wegen der großen dürre sind
die beiden trocken und die pharma
möchten ihr vieh möglichst schnell
loswerden
[Musik]
du kaufst sie in kleinen herden also
alle zusammen
doch heute wird ruth ohne rinder
zurückfahren
das geld sitzt bei ruth alles andere als
locker
es läuft nicht gut zum überleben braucht
der carrer neue einkünfte aber gut ist
eine kämpferin
[Musik]
afrika weckt sehnsüchte und fernweh
der kontinent der klischees ist ruth
neue heimat
dort leben und arbeiten zu dürfen das
erscheint vielen als ein großer traum
betrogen als vision mit druckerschwärze
bereitschaft von der folge dass sich die
fahrt raum und mit der örtlichkeit es
ins ferne vierziger und die sind
ziemlich schade hat vorurteil bestätigt
ein afrika geführt
es ist so viel alptraum hat die und
schwierig ganz rund und um die tat
schnitt lasse ich bin dann ins land bis
zu zwölf jungen und mädchen pro jahr
versuchen auf der akteure ihr leben ohne
drogen wieder in den griff zu kriegen
für die teilnehmer ist es die letzte
chance vor dem endgültigen absturz und
russell crowe und
verhaltensauffälligkeiten gut leitet die
farm und ist verantwortlich für die
finanzen ein team von therapeuten und
betreuer kümmert sich um die
jugendlichen mit auf daktari leben noch
zehn schwarze arbeiter und ihre familie
nur die hälfte der therapieplätze des
reha programms ist besetzt
im moment gibt es mehr personal als
teilnehmer
dabei ist das therapieprogramm sehr
erfolgreich und mit 210 franken pro tag
und teilnehmer günstiger als
vergleichbare angebote in der schweiz
seit beginn des programms 1997 haben nur
wenige das jahr einsamkeit arbeit und
therapie vorzeitig abgebrochen ruth und
ihr team kämpfen gegen das vorurteil
junkies auf steuerkosten einen
abenteuerurlaub in afrika zu schenken
ämter und institutionen tun sich schwer
damit drogensüchtige im ausland zu
therapieren
sagt ari ist die idee von emmerich er
war roots große liebe und ehe man 51
prozent der farm gehörten ihm dem
charmanten und ruhelosen abenteurer der
bei den frauen gut ankam
[Musik]
als ich ihm eine chinesin verliebte
wollte er die scheidung
er heiratete neu und verließ die farm
wenig später kam ihm auch 2011 bei einem
autounfall ums leben
[Musik]
seit der scheidung führt ruth die farm
ein sprung ins kalte wasser
für die frau die sich bis dahin immer
ein wenig hinter dem rücken ihres mannes
versteckt im us wirklich immer
wirtschaft schöpfer was da merkt man
hilft das team mitteilte sieht er hat
irritiert wird startverfahren der
schwäche zeigten platz freuen sich
[Musik]
schlechte nachrichten aus der hauptstadt
windhuk ruth holt die vergangenheit ein
denn die chinesische witwe ihres
ex-mannes immer will mehr als die hälfte
der dakar riefer
[Musik]
termin beim anwalt gemeinsam mit ihrem
mitarbeiter lukas sucht ruth
juristischen rat
[Musik]
das von ihm handschriftlich verfasste
und unterschriebene testament weist
seine neue frau als erbin aus in der
schweiz wäre dieser letzte wille
rechtsgültig aber in namibia ist die
unterschrift eines zeugen nötig weil
immer schweizerischer doppelbürger war
muss das höchste gericht namibias nun
entscheiden ob das testament
einheimischen oder schweizer recht
unterliegt gut muss warten
sie ist überrumpelt eigentlich war
abgemacht dass sie und emo sich im
todesfall gegenseitig beerben
andere chance
auf traum der sms werde zerstört
wir beschlossen sind
sehr lang
und mit einem smash bros
frauen sind geschäftig und viel weiter
aber
unter der finanzierungspläne trotzdem
technik
sollten ihm aus 51 prozent der farm an
seine witwe gehen dann wäre der verkauf
sicher und daktari verloren
[Musik]
so bekommt die große liebe die in einer
freundschaft endete plötzlich einen
bitteren nachgeschmack
[Musik]
punkt 4 6
im ersten moment ist die sexy frank
abschlepper jetzt geführte radtour jetzt
glaubt weil glaubte menschen gerade
diese freundschaft ist alles und
zusammen gemacht und es war auf der farm
geht der alltag weiter
roland koch wanderte vor 15 jahren mit
ruth und ihrem damaligen mann immer nach
namibia aus der berner kümmert sich um
die lebensmittelvorräte das fleisch wird
von ihm eingelegt geräuchert und später
zu trocken fleisch verarbeitet die reste
gehen an ruth geparde einkaufen muss
wohl an den oldie barranco für alle die
auf der farm leben ist die stadt eine
abwechslung
gestern waren wir in lemgo bei der
stockstraße da war ein unfall
drei autos haben sich ineinander
geschoben einer beim anderen hinten
drauf alles schön in einer reihe
28.000 einwohner hat die stadt und liegt
zwei stunden von der form entfernt
einmal pro woche werden die daktari
vorräte aufgestockt
ihre hat teilnehmer können von ihrem
taschengeld süßigkeiten zeitungen und
zigaretten bestellen
alkohol ist verboten
roland schaut gut und genau auf sein
budget und die preise die farm hat für
das therapieprogramm und sein personal
hohe ausgaben
denn namibia ist kein billig land die
meisten lebensmittel tabak kosmetika
oder pflegeprodukte sind importiert und
kosten daher beinahe so viel in europa
drei versand von heimat
auch die schwarzen daktari arbeiter
nutzen roland fahrten aus um einzukaufen
pünktlich sind sie nie
der straße läuft es mir jetzt gerade und
der vbb abo dass er über warten ja wahr
ist ja in euro bist du denn jetzt bitte
[Musik]
genau wie ruth lebt roland seit 15
jahren in namibia
ihm ist es gelungen sich mit den weißen
fahnen aus der nachbarschaft zu
arrangieren
es ist unheimlich schwierig aber ich
glaube es würde schon auf sie wenn sie
kontakt zu den anderen frau machen gut
hättest du die nachbarn ist nicht
einfach
obwohl wenn der tank leer ist kommt
immer ein farmer zuliefen
aber die kontaktpflege bleibt zäh und
nicht nur weil dieser herr durchblicken
lässt jetzt auch singend zu sein egal
schweizer und noch als frauchen
wirtschaft schützen und was die tagen
richtig nah sind ruth vor allem ihre
acht geparde
ich fand dass seine vorfahren
hätte die farm er wilde tiere wäre das
ein zusatzgeschäft touristen könnten
dann zebras giraffen oder nashörner
bestaunen aber für den kauf und die
haltung von wildtieren fehlt es auf
daktari an know how und noch scheint
ruth ihre lieblinge nicht teilen zu
wollen
im sitzen namens computer medientross
verstand laster angesetzter toni ungern
zur cap markt irgendwie glaub da macht
diese fuß spüre dass sich freut der tier
und jetzt ganz wenig bringen
gestern 52 knips und josef fritzl nur
gut unterwegs zu nachbarn
es gibt eine einladung auf die schönfeld
fahren
ein stück deutschland mitten in der
namibischen wüste das
willkommensgeschenk für ruth ist ein
gepard die katze ist ein einzeltier und
droht zu vereinsamen ihr gefährte wurde
von wilden pavianen in seinem gehege
getötet ruth und ihr mitarbeiter heiko
beim herrn des hauses hartwich von
seydlitz familie lebt seit drei
generationen in afrika die farm verdient
gutes geld mit der trophäenjagd
rundflügen und safaris in ganz namibia
und der und der weist der pavian weist
unter reist vater wir danken dir für
dieses essen wir danken dir für diesen
tag für alle die bewahrung heute alles
was wir erleben durften auch mit dem
flugzeug
danke jetzt für dieses zusammensein in
jesu christi namen
guten appetit hallo entschuldige wieder
beten das ist gehört zu unserer kultur
hier sind größter kunde vor allem
amerikanische und deutsche jäger lassen
sich das abenteuer und ihren wandschmuck
einiges kosten die gehören auch weg
das ist jetzt schon alte abgekämpfter
wird der run der gehört nicht mehr in
die erde
der gepard macht sich auf die reise in
sein neues zuhause zeit für profi tipps
für die haltung von wildtieren und du
wirst hegel abschlüsse machen darüber
alte tiere muss tor ausknipsen und damit
kannst du deine gäste versorgen deines
schwarzen versorgung das waisenheim in
kalk fällt versorgen und danny gepaart
mit den apfel glaubt wenn ich mit wild
anfang hatte ich ja ganz viel
unterstützung
du brauchst ein anderes herz weil das
keine ärzten viel zu tun gutes werden
wir bei dir noch einrichten
ganz verzichten straße muss man auch
fehler gemacht
ja ich werde mich gespürt und
kontakt zu kommen
und das wird die zukunft der andere ganz
klar
erste zaghafte schritte in das daktari
gehege der neue kollege riskiert schon
mal einen blick
die freude über den neuen gepard klingt
ab aber in root arbeitet es hier anwalt
bittet sie wegen des testaments nach
windhoek hintergrund
das projekt wird mit so viel herzblut
und 600 bluttests sitzung zurück in
windhoek das höchste gericht namibias
hat über die rechtsgültigkeit von ihm
aus testament entschieden schneller als
gedacht
ob das jetzt ob die unterschrift jetzt
wirklich die unterschrift oder die die
zeitschrift star von von hendrik abrät
ist es eigentlich unmöglich dass sie die
farbe mit zunehmend könnte also für mich
ist also ziemlich klar dass das
testament was unterschrieben worden ist
durch ihn allein kann man nicht sagen
dass es wirklich
er war und vor allem ohne zeugen ist
sehr schwierig dort zu beweisen dass wir
diese absicht war so nach namibischen
gesetz wäre das nicht akzeptieren dass
das darwin theresa belastet sie und fand
mit riester klaus stein vom herz das
thema abschließen und taktisch fahren
das heißt man kann jetzt mit frischem
mut machen
[Musik]
es geht ein ruck durch daktari gut
konnte zwei dutzend rinder ersteigern
für die zucht den verkauf und
eigenbedarf
[Musik]
die therapie geht weiter ruth reist bald
wieder nach europa um neue teilnehmer zu
finden
falls nicht ständig alle plätze im
programm besetzt sind setzt daktari
jetzt zusätzlich auf tour ist das erste
gästehaus oben in den hügeln ist im bau
weitere sollen folgen
mit dem kauf und der haltung von
wildtieren auf dari möchte ruht noch
mehr abenteuerlustige besucher auf die
fahren locken
um zu fotografieren nicht zum schießen
[Musik]
mit flexit probleme niemals problemen
sondern als neue herausforderung mit mit
viel fracht und positiv abhebt geschäft
das man dort parkt und vision angeführt
[Musik]
[Applaus]